we're in Thailand's pristine southeast
in nakhon SI thammarat the tropical
rainforest rises above the secluded bays
like most farmers here one shot some
done doesn't cultivate rice he
specialized in growing fruits here we
have the sweet and sour mangosteens and
the yellow durian delicate but with a
strong fragrance both sell really well
the problem here is irrigation by the
end of the dry season water is scarce
this is my reservoir during the rainy
season it fills up on its own
the water trickles down the slope and
irrigates the fruit trees during the dry
season they have to tap river water and
feed it over here through these pipes I
adore my thumb guiding and cordon very
hot water is a problem for everyone here
so the farmers in this village have
joined forces with help from the German
development aid agency gee I said
they're building a weir it's meant to
slow the river down as it flows towards
the ocean the sacks are biodegradable
they leave behind what's inside them
sand and stones we tried it before using
cement but that's a dead material that's
destroyed by the water and that's why we
use bamboo and other natural materials
that's why we call it a living where the
wire slows the river down that way more
water trickles into the surrounding
nature allowing it to rejuvenate
saplings on the edge of the dam will
hopefully take root and provide
additional stability to keep back the
floods during the rains the local
community is strengthened by work
together on the project
everyone pitches in though some aren't
here by choice I'm doing community work
because I failed a drug test
but I think it's quite cool to help here
with my friends meanwhile work continues
on the dam now school children are
loading the sacks many are simply
enjoying the cool water
Farmar one-shots undone wants to check
the progress I think we'll be done by
the end of the year and then all the
villages at the tardy river here will
benefit from our living where now the
sky is heavy with rain and soon it
begins pouring down the first big
monsoon of the year has come